one time somebody tweeted at me and was
like good morning to everyone but
especially good morning to blake griffin
and his ties
yeah you heard that right
blake griffin reacting to this viral
photo
and his status as a sex symbol i thought
it was hilarious
meanwhile the nba superstar is busier
than ever
juggling his career with the detroit
pistons and
launching a new podcast through audible
called the pursuit of healthiness with
blake griffin
ultimately i hope that people walk away
a better version themselves
outside of work the dad of two opened up
about his family
and revealed he's open to finding love i
am single right now are you looking what
catches your eye
blake griffin one of the busiest guys in
the world
you're launching a podcast the pursuit
of healthiness
what inspired this decision i've always
been
very interested in health and wellness
like even as a kid my mom was
a very very healthy person was always
reading nutritionist books
i was a health and exercise science
major in college and then when i got to
the mba i sort of just always picked the
brains of
you know our trainers and doctors i was
like if i'm going to have a podcast why
not interview people who i really want
to like find out some information from
and also i think it's just sort of a
daunting world in general
um unless you truly understand it i
think there can be a lot of
misinformation out there so
hopefully this sort of bridges that gap
a little bit yeah i've listened to two
episodes and the way that it's just such
a casual
conversation it's really easy to digest
for you you're used to being on the
other end you're used to being the one
being interviewed
so i'm curious how are you liking being
the one who asks the questions
it's obviously challenging but it's sort
of like a mental workout because you're
just like sort of trying to take
take all this information in at one time
and you're trying to decipher okay like
do i should i follow up with this check
over that like oh let's dig in here more
there but at first i was like
it was it was completely out of my
element so uh hopefully the
the first first episodes we recorded
don't reflect that but
i'm sure they do i can i can vouch that
you totally crushed it so i mean
i'm curious did you go to any of your
celebrity friends people who have
podcasts or or talk show hosts
did you go to anybody for advice i sort
of made a conscious decision not to do
that i just wanted to study the tim
ferriss podcast dak shepard joe rogan
and i think those those are really
really interesting interviews
not because like they're they're giving
you so much information but like you
said it just feels like a casual
conversation
who's your bucket list guest to have on
the show
that's a great question i think like um
i think michelle obama is in all her
work and everything
health related there's tons of people
that are doing awesome stuff but you
know she's she's
she's the goat you're blake griffin i
mean i have to imagine that's an easy
phone call
yeah we're working on it you know i
think the coolest thing about the
podcast is that it covers so much ground
and you talk about so many different
things is there anything
that is off limits and what topics
are you most excited to delve into for
me personally i think one that i didn't
realize i was going to be so
into was just like mental health i think
like especially
as a man especially a in the sports
world
i think feelings and and and
mental uh health is not something that's
really talked about or brought up a lot
and i think
just by having this conversation uh you
start to normalize it a bit better i
think it's just important for
people to hear that even people like
michael b jordan
anthony perowski or anybody is dealing
with these things it doesn't matter what
line of work
where you come from your background your
ethnicity your religion your gender
you have to deal with these things and i
think that's just important for people
to hear
you know you you went really um into
the topic of anxiety and mental health
with like you said michael b
jordan and chelsea handler they really
were huge proponents
of of therapy and working things out
with a professional
is that something that you have
experienced or that you have done and
what was your experience like with it if
so yeah i definitely
i i have seen a therapist and i sort of
had this view of
like how you see the movies you know
where you like lay down on the couch and
you really get into it
um and i i walked away realizing that
like it's not so much me going to this
person and them telling me
the answers that i need but it's us or
myself
working towards these answers you know
on my own
um with their guided help sort of i want
people to know
like if you need help like it's
very it's beyond okay to go do that seek
that out and just try it because
i think people will be happier healthier
and
maybe be able to help someone in turn i
thank you for bringing attention to that
i think it's so important
um of course when fans hear blake
griffin is putting out a podcast their
ears immediately perk up
and they think oh my gosh i'm gonna get
this peek into his life
um off of the court and of course a
component of that could be
your dating life i know you're a very
private person
so i'm just curious how do you as such a
public figure with people who are always
so interested in what you're doing
how do you navigate all of that uh i
think it's trial and error i think you
each you know as you get older it
changes i think you take things slow and
you really like try to get to know
somebody
um you know like rushing into something
can be
you know can be great for some people
but sometimes detrimental for others so
i think for me making sure that i i
really know
and trust someone um before you get get
to that level
uh is important but um it's always
challenging i don't think anybody has
like that perfect
formula i mean look i once saw you at
alfred coffee here in los
angeles one of my favorites and there
was a swarm of paparazzi outside and
everybody was just like clamoring to get
a shot of what you were doing or who you
were with
i mean how do you react to that and
that's being part of your life
i mean i think you you know for me
life could be so much worse um you know
if that's like one thing that's like
you know annoying then um i'll gladly
take it
it's just not something that you can sit
and truly complain about could it be
could you want a little bit more privacy
of course but
um you know i'm blessed to be able to
play basketball and do what i love doing
um and have the friends and family
around me that i have so
um i can't really can't really add that
to like a high list of complaints
the fans want to know is he single or is
he seeing someone
yeah i'm single right now i'm uh i'm
just kind of focusing on
i guess myself and uh my my family my
kids
and my career and the things i'm doing
which is
which is nice so we'll see what catches
your eye
honesty i guess uh you know somebody
like i said earlier somebody you can
trust and um
uh that you really like genuinely have a
good time with
i think that catches my eye the most
well you bring up your beautiful family
i know you've got
an almost seven-year-old yeah almost
seven saturday actually yeah i'll be
seven
august first yeah wow happy early
birthday to ford i know you've got
little finley
i'm curious are they following in either
mom or dad's footsteps are you seeing
little glimpses of them and possibly
what the future might look like
as a kid my dad was a basketball coach
and i played for him and he didn't
really let us
start playing sports until we were six
years old so i sort of did the same
thing with ford he started a little bit
before that but
yeah he loves sports but the thing that
i want him to
to do is just have fun with it it's
never something i'll push on him but
um yeah he sort of loves it on his own
and a little fin we're
we're still waiting she's a she's a a
little bit
she's a wild card always trying to keep
up with her big brother
um and very smart and very she already
has like her opinion
so even at three most the time she's
doing whatever ford does but
she's just uh i love her i love both
obviously but she's just so
different and so uh still her own person
that
we're holding off on sports for her for
now do they have any idea
who mom and dad are that they're you
know legendary athletes
um i don't know like what their thoughts
are about it but um you know
they're definitely aware of you know how
big a role sports plays
um in in my life and their life as well
you know
i gotta end on a very hard-hitting piece
of journalism here
blake i think you have to know at this
point that everyone views you as a
total sex symbol and i would love to
know how your how you react to that i
honestly haven't given much thought to
be honest uh i appreciate it
i appreciate anybody that has anything
kind to say because you know
in 2020 in this in this climate you can
hear a lot of negative stuff about
yourselves
i really appreciate the fans and uh the
people who are genuine about that but
um yeah i just you know gotta gotta stay
focused
do you have fun with the tweets that
just kind of run rampant every time you
either
post a shirtless photo and you know your
thighs are like a national
treasure at this point do you ever see
those tweets and how does it make you
feel
yeah i see from time to time i see
something one of my favorites was
i i was shooting something one time i
took a picture with a friend of mine
jimmy o yang
and i don't know what it was maybe it's
the chair or how i was sitting but
um i always see that picture from time
to time and one time somebody tweeted at
me and was like good morning to everyone
but especially good morning to blake
griffin and his ties
i thought it was hilarious so yeah i do
appreciate when people have fun with it
like that
um because it's uh it's definitely funny
you